This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the year 1596, a cartographer in what is today the Netherlands noticed is startling anomaly. Abraham Ortelius observed that if you moved around the continents of the known world like pieces in a jigsaw puzzle, the western coastline of Africa fit like a glove around the eastern coastline of South America. At first, the anomaly was dismissed as a weird coincidence. The idea that the continents of Africa and South America could have once been joined together seemed absurd because sitting between them now was the vast immensity of the Atlantic Ocean. them now was the vast immensity of the Atlantic Ocean. In time however, scientists realized that continents do move around.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。1596年，一位生活在当今荷兰境内的制图师注意到一个惊人的异常现象。亚伯拉罕·奥特柳斯观察到，如果你像拼图一样把已知世界的各大洲移动一下，非洲的西海岸就会像手套一样严丝合缝地契合南美洲的东海岸。起初，这个异常现象被当成了一个奇怪的巧合。非洲和南美洲这两个大陆曾经连在一起的想法似乎荒谬绝伦，因为现在它们之间隔着浩瀚无垠的大西洋。然而随着时间的推移，科学家们意识到大陆确实是在移动的。
What is today South America was in fact once attached to Africa. Intersecting lines of evidence soon began to come together. The fossil record for example shows similar species in areas that were once contiguous. Abraham Ortelius' observation was a crucial clue in the development of the theory of continental drift. Anomalies have long been a powerful driver of scientific invention. of scientific invention. Paying attention to places where things look odd and weird can tell you where your maps and models of the world are wrong. If you have the humility and patience to sit with anomalies, instead of simply dismissing them, they can teach you things about the world that you didn't know before.
如今的南美洲实际上曾经与非洲连在一起。相互交织的证据很快开始汇聚起来。例如，化石记录显示，曾经相连的地区存在着相似的物种。亚伯拉罕·奥特柳斯的观察是大陆漂移理论发展过程中的一个关键线索。长期以来，异常现象一直是科学发明强大的推动力。关注那些看起来古怪和奇怪的地方，能告诉你世界的地图和模型哪里出了错。如果你有谦逊和耐心的态度去面对异常现象，而不是简单地忽视它们，它们就能教给你以前所不知道的世界奥秘。
This week on Hidden Brain, how a series of anomalies in the way people get money, spend money and save money led to the development of the field of behavioral economics. Every day of our lives we make decisions both trivial and momentous. What will we eat for lunch today? Will we ride the elevator or take the stairs? How much money will we save from our paycheck and how much will we spend? It turns out there's a hidden logic to the way we make such choices, a logic often not rooted in rationality. Richard Thaler is a behavioural economist at the University of Chicago. He has spent decades studying the psychology of our everyday choices.
本期的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：人们获取金钱、消费金钱和储蓄金钱方式中的一系列异常现象，是如何催生出行为经济学这一领域的。在我们生活的每一天里，我们都会做出大大小小的决定。今天午饭吃什么？我们是坐电梯还是走楼梯？我们要从薪水中存下多少钱，又会花掉多少钱？事实证明，我们做出这些选择的方式背后隐藏着一种逻辑，而这种逻辑往往并非植根于理性。理查德·塞勒是芝加哥大学的一位行为经济学家。他花了数十年时间研究我们日常选择背后的心理学。
Richard Thaler, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shaka. Good to talk to you again. Richard, I'd like to start at the very beginning. I understand that your dad was an actuary, essentially a job that involves using math to help businesses analyze risk. He wanted you to follow in his footsteps. Why didn't you?
理查德·塞勒，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。很高兴再次与你交谈。理查德，我想从最开始聊起。据我了解，你的父亲是一名精算师，这基本上是一份利用数学帮助企业分析风险的工作。他希望你子承父业。你为什么没有这样做？
Well, that's a good question. Being an actuary, first of all, it's hard and second of all, it's boring. And second of all, it's boring. Sorry to all the actuaries. But he did encourage me. And I took the first one of the nine or 10 actuarial exams, which, and I thought, oh God, I don't wanna, I don't wanna do this.
嗯，这是个好问题。首先，精算师这行很难，其次，它很无聊。而且其次，它很无聊。向所有的精算师致歉。但他确实鼓励过我。我参加了那九到十门精算考试中的第一门，考完我想，天哪，我可不想，我可不想做这个。
And I had one insight about myself, which was, I'm not a good subordinate. I have a lifetime of deans that will testify to this. So I didn't want a career path that had me starting out as some cog in a large organization. It wouldn't have gone well. I see. And so you chose instead a career in academia,
我对自己的认识有一个顿悟，那就是：我不是一个优秀的下属。我有一生中无数教务长可以为此作证。所以我不想要那种从大组织里的小齿轮开始做起的职业轨迹。那不会有好结果的。我明白了。所以你转而选择了学术界，
which of course is a very definition of a bunch of cats running in every direction possible. When you got to graduate school at the University of Rochester, I understand that you were not necessarily seen as the most promising student. An advisor of yours once said that we did not expect much from him. Tell me about that. What happened in graduate school? It's true that I was not considered an outstanding student. And I think I was not destined to be a great economist.
这当然是一群人朝着各个可能方向乱跑的完美写照。当你去罗切斯特大学读研究生时，据我了解，你当时并不一定被看作是最有前途的学生。你的一位导师曾说过，我们对他的期望不高。跟我聊聊这个吧。研究生院发生了什么？我确实不被认为是一个出色的学生。而且我认为我注定不会成为一名伟大的经济学家。
I don't think that I have the skill set that leading economists have. You know, I'm better in math than the average person, but not in the top 1% of 1%. And so I faced a dilemma, which is that, you know, it's like if my goal was to become a major league baseball player, I wasn't that good at hitting or or fielding so so maybe I need to think of something else. What Richard found himself drawn to was stories. He started collecting anecdotes of people behaving in odd ways, at least odd in terms of what standard economics might predict. what standard economics might predict. I became preoccupied with these examples. I called the list.
我认为我不具备顶尖经济学家所拥有的技能组合。你知道的，我的数学比普通人好，但并非处于顶尖百分之一的百分之一。所以我面临着一个困境，这就好比如果我的目标是成为一名美国职棒大联盟球员，我并不擅长击球或防守，所以也许我需要考虑点别的。理查德发现自己被故事所吸引。他开始收集人们表现出怪异行为的轶事，至少从标准经济学所能预测的角度来看是怪异的。标准经济学所能预测的角度来看是怪异的。我开始全神贯注于这些例子。我把这份清单称作。
And Newton had his apple. I have my cashews. So one of these stories is I invited some other graduate students over for dinner one night and put out a large bowl of cashews and cocktails. And there was something cooking in the oven that was smelling very good. People started dev eat more cashews than we should. So I took the bowl and hid it in the kitchen.
牛顿有他的苹果。我有我的腰果。其中一个故事是，有一天我邀请了一些研究生来家里吃晚饭，并端出了一大碗腰果和鸡尾酒。烤箱里正烤着什么东西，闻起来非常香。大家开始吃起腰果，吃得比我们应该吃的还要多。于是我把碗拿走，藏在了厨房里。
And I came back and everybody was happy. There was, oh, thank God you got rid of those sad. But this being a group of economic graduate students, we immediately began discussing the fact that, wait a minute, we're not allowed to be happy about this because the first principle of economics is that more choices always make you better off. Before my rash act, we had a choice of eating cashews or not. Now we didn't have that choice. How can we be happy?
然后我回来了，每个人都很高兴。大家都在说，哦，谢天神你把那些烦人的东西拿走了。但既然这是一群经济学研究生，我们便立刻开始讨论这样一个事实：等一下，我们不应该为此感到高兴，因为经济学的第一条原则是，越多的选择总是能让你过得更好。在我采取鲁莽行动之前，我们可以选择吃腰果或不吃。现在我们没有这个选择了。我们怎么还能高兴得起来呢？
Now, you might say it's obvious why Richard's guests prefer to have the cashews removed. They lack the self-control to limit the number of nuts they popped into their mouths. But Richard noticed that when economists build models of how people make choices, the models ignored how ordinary people might worry about a problem like self-control. In effect, an economic model of people's dinner choices might assume that if you give people the choice between eating lots of cashews or saving their appetites to eat a nice dinner, people would make the rational choice to not ruin their appetites. The problem of self-control in economic decision-making was in anomaly that the models ignored.
现在，你可能会说，理查德的客人们为什么更愿意把腰果拿走，这是显而易见的。他们缺乏控制力，无法克制自己往嘴里塞坚果的数量。但理查德注意到，当经济学家构建关于人们如何做出选择的模型时，这些模型忽略了普通人可能会如何担心自控力之类的问题。实际上，关于人们晚餐选择的经济学家模型可能会假设，如果你给人们提供吃很多腰果还是留着胃口吃一顿丰盛晚餐的选择，人们会做出理性的选择，不破坏自己的胃口。经济决策中的自控力问题正是模型所忽略的一个异常现象。
Another item on Richard's list came from a professor, Richard Rosette. Yeah, so Professor Rosette, he was a wine lover and he had bottles that he had purchased 20 years earlier that had appreciated greatly in value. And so let's say he had a bottle that was now worth $200 that he had paid $20 for. And he would never dream of paying that much money to buy such a bottle. But he also wouldn't sell any of those bottles. There was a one shop in Rochester, and there was a guy who said, you know, I'll buy those bottles from you.
理查德清单上的另一个项目来自一位教授，理查德·罗塞特。是的，罗塞特教授是一位葡萄酒爱好者，他有一些是20年前买的瓶装酒，这些酒已经大幅升值了。比方说，他有一瓶酒现在值200美元，而他当年买的时候只花了20美元。他做梦也想不到会花那么多钱去买这样一瓶酒。但他也绝不会卖掉这些酒中的任何一瓶。罗切斯特有一家酒店，有个人说，你知道的，我从你手里买下这些酒。
But Richard Rosette was not interested in making a deal. And so he wouldn't buy and he wouldn't sell. And in fact, he wouldn't pay more than $30 for a bottle of wine, but he would drink a bottle that costs 200. So is that bottle worth 200 to him or 30 know, I took that example and I started thinking about it that there are lots of situations in which we won't give something up that we wouldn't pay a lot of money to keep. And another principle of economics and a very important one is the cost of something is defined as the opportunity cost. And when Professor Rosev went and drank one of those expensive bottles, he wasn't thinking about that
但理查德·罗塞特对做这笔交易毫无兴趣。所以他既不买也不卖。事实上，对于一瓶酒，他绝不会花超过30美元去买，但他却会喝掉一瓶价值200美元的酒。所以那瓶酒对他来说价值200美元还是30美元呢？我知道，我拿这个例子开始思考，我们有很多这样的情况：我们不会放弃某样东西，但如果让我们花一大笔钱去保留它，我们是绝对不肯的。经济学的另一个原则、也是一个非常重要的原则是，某样东西的成本定义为机会成本。而当罗塞特教授去喝其中一瓶昂贵的酒时，他并没有把这看作是
as costing him $200. And in fact, many years later, my friend El Darshafeer and I wrote a paper about this that we called invest now, drink later, spend never. Because that seems to be the way wine collectors and lovers think about things. If I buy a case of Bordeaux that I planned to drink in 20 years, that's an investment. Then when I go to drink one, well, that doesn't cost me anything. It's in the seller.
花了他200美元。事实上，很多年后，我和我的朋友埃尔达·沙菲尔写了一篇关于这个的论文，我们把它叫做“现在投资，以后饮用，永不花钱”。因为这似乎就是葡萄酒收藏家和爱好者们的思考方式。如果我买了一箱波尔多葡萄酒，并打算在20年后再喝，那是一笔投资。然后当我打开喝一瓶时，嗯，那并没有花我任何钱。它本来就在酒窖里。
And so I never spend any money. And it's all free. It's great. Again, this was not the way economists would model people's behavior. A bottle of wine that costs $200 is worth, well, $200. But in Richard Rosette's mind, the value of the bottle seemed to fluctuate depending on the context. A third anomaly that Richard put on his list of odd behaviors came from an incident with
所以我从来不花钱。而且一切都是免费的。太棒了。同样，这不是经济学家对人们行为建模的方式。一瓶价值200美元的葡萄酒，嗯，就值200美元。但在理查德·罗塞特的心中，这瓶酒的价值似乎会随着语境的不同而上下波动。理查德列出的第三个奇怪行为的异常现象，源于他和
his friend, Jeffrey. The two of them received tickets to see a pro basketball game in Buffalo. So, yeah, we were given these two tickets and as often happens in upstate New York in the winter, there was snow and more than more than a trivial amount of snow. So normally the drive from Rochester to Buffalo would be a little over an hour, no big deal. But this snowstorm was significant. And I have a phone call with Jeffrey and he says, well, no, we shouldn't go to the game.
他的朋友杰弗里之间的一次经历。他们俩得到了两张去布法罗看职业篮球比赛的门票。所以，是的，我们得到了这两张票，就像纽约州北部冬天的常见情况一样，当时下雪了，而且下的雪远远超过了微不足道的数量。所以通常从罗切斯特开车到布法罗只要一个多小时，没什么大不了的。但这次暴风雪非同寻常。我和杰弗里通了电话，他说，嗯，我们不应该去看比赛了。
It doesn't make any sense in the snow. Yeah. But if we had paid for those tickets, we'd be going. And now, you know, this is what economists call the sunk cost fallacy as you can pay right and the idea is suppose we had paid a hundred dollars each for these tickets yeah that money is gone yeah going to the game in no way recaptures that money it's sunk and you, you should ignore it. And there are expressions like let bygones be bygones, or don't cry over spilled milk.
在雪地里去完全没有意义。是的。但是如果我们为这些票付过钱，我们就会去了。现在，你知道的，这就是经济学家所说的沉没成本谬误，你可以付钱对吧，这个想法是，假设我们为这些票每人付了一百美元，是的，那笔钱已经没了，是的，去看比赛根本无法把那笔钱追回来，那是沉没的成本，你，你应该忽略它。并且有这样的表达，比如让过去的事情过去吧，或者不要为打翻的牛奶哭泣。
Don't throw good money after bad. Right, right. Right, so all these kinds of expressions are trying to cure people of the sunk cost fallacy. And we have them because people don't follow the economist's dictums. So if we take these these three, you can think of them as prototypes. And for a while, that's all the words. I'm using stories I would tell to annoy my fellow economists. I wanted to ask you about that. When you shared these with your colleagues, did they, did they say, wow, that's really interesting. These are violations of our models. Or did
不要把好钱扔进坏钱里。对，对。对，所以所有这些类型的表达都试图治愈人们的沉没成本谬误。我们之所以有这些，是因为人们不遵循经济学家的教条。所以如果我们把这三个拿出来，你可以把它们看作是原型。有一段时间，所有的言论仅此而已。我用这些故事来惹恼我的同行经济学家。我想问你关于这个的事。当你与同事分享这些时，他们，他们有没有说，哇，这真的很有趣。这些是对我们模型的违背。还是他们
they say, here's Richard being irritating again? The latter. I mean, well, I would say there were some economists who found these examples intriguing, but the vast majority thought they were silly and lightweight. And Professor Rosen, the guy who said that they didn't expect much of me, told me to go back to doing real work. This was just a distraction. When we come back, how a chance meeting helped Richard realize that his anomalies were more than just oddities. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan.
说，看，理查德又在惹人生气了？是后者。我的意思是，我会说有一些经济学家觉得这些例子很有趣，但绝大多数人认为它们很愚蠢，微不足道。而罗森教授，那个说过对我期望不高的人，叫我回去做真正的工作。这只是分心。当我们回来时，一次偶然的相遇如何帮助理查德意识到他的异常现象不仅仅是古怪。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
Economist Richard Thaler began bucking the conventional wisdom of his field right from the time he was in grad school. Classical economic theory held that human beings were always optimizing, but the people Richard knew in his personal life weren't anything like that at all. He started keeping track of examples where people he knew deviated from the classical model of the rational economic actor. He called us collection of anecdotes, the list. Richard, you tell the story of a friend Lee and his wife,
经济学家理查德·塞勒从研究生院起就开始挑战他这一领域的传统智慧。古典经济学理论认为人类总是在不断优化，但理查德在个人生活中认识的人根本不是那样。他开始追踪他认识的人偏离理性经济人古典模型的例子。他把他收集的轶事称为“清单”。理查德，你讲过一个关于你的朋友李和他的妻子的故事，
their economic conundrum had to do with a very expensive sweater. Tell me Lee's story. So yeah, Lee's story was that he had admired some cashmere sweater at the department store and decided, no, it was too much money. He couldn't justify paying for it. But then was immensely pleased when his wife gave him that sweater for Christmas. Now Leon and his wife had all joint, check out your accounts. They have one household budget. So how can it be that the sweater was too expensive for him to buy? But great for his wife to buy out of the same pool of money.
他们的经济难题与一件非常昂贵的毛衣有关。给我讲讲李的故事吧。所以，是的，李的故事是这样的：他在百货公司看中了一件羊绒毛衣，觉得太贵了，不值得买。但他妻子在圣诞节送给他这件毛衣时，他感到无比高兴。现在，李昂和他的妻子所有的支票账户都是共同的。他们有一个家庭预算。那么怎么会这件毛衣对他自己买来说太贵了？但对于他妻子从同一笔钱里买下来却很棒呢？
same pool of money. One last story from the list, this is your friend Stan who used to get terrible hay fever when he mowed his lawn. And so you came up with a very common senseical solution for his problem. What did you suggest? I said Stan, why don't you hire a neighborhood kid to mow the lawn, pay the kid 10 bucks, and then you'll be done with it. And he said, no, he won't pay somebody to do that. And I said, well, how much would you charge to mow your neighbor's lawn? And he wouldn't mow his neighbor's lawn for $100. And he didn't think of himself as in the business of providing lawn mowing services.
同一笔钱。清单上的最后一个故事，这是你的朋友斯坦，他以前在修剪草坪时会得可怕的花粉热。所以你想出了一个非常符合常识的解决方案来解决他的问题。你建议了什么？我说，斯坦，你为什么不雇个附近的邻居小孩来修剪草坪，付给那孩子10美元，然后你就搞定了。而他说，不，他不会付钱给别人来做这件事。我说，好吧，那你收多少钱才肯帮你邻居修剪草坪？他连100美元都不肯帮邻居修剪草坪。而且他并不认为自己是从事提供草坪修剪服务业务的人。
If he were doing that, it would take more than $10 to get him to do it. But yet he wasn't willing to pay the neighborhood kid 10 bucks to get the kid to do it. When Stan decided to mo his own lawn instead of paying a kid 10 dollars to do it, he was saying in effect that mooring the lawn was worth less than 10 dollars to him. So why was he not willing to mo someone else's lawn for a hundred dollars? Again, for non-economists, there is a simple answer to that question. We are not just economic actors. We care about social norms, relationships, and hierarchies. If my neighbor asked me to mow his lawn because he was feeling sick, I would be delighted
如果他在做那个，要让他做这事可不止10美元。然而他却不愿意付给邻居小孩10美元让小孩来做。当斯坦决定自己修剪草坪而不是付给小孩10美元让他做时，他实际上是在说，修剪草坪对他的价值还不到10美元。那他为什么不愿意为一百美元帮别人修剪草坪呢？同样，对非经济学家来说，这个问题有一个简单的答案。我们不仅仅是经济人。我们关心社会规范、人际关系和等级制度。如果我的邻居因为身体不舒服而请我帮他修剪草坪，我会非常乐意
to help. But if he offered to pay me $100, I would feel insulted. In the period after World War II, economics had come to ignore such psychological complexities. Economists created an archetype of people as rational economic actors. This simplification allowed economists to describe the behavior of people using mathematical models, but they ignored a vast range of psychological factors that influence our choices. The people in Richard's list of anomalies did not merely try to maximize their economic self-interest. They were guided instead by feelings, worries, and biases. You could call such behavior irrational, but Richard says he dislikes the term. And the reason is that it has all kinds of connotations to different people. And if you say something
帮忙。但如果他提出付给我100美元，我会觉得受了侮辱。在二战后的时期，经济学已经开始忽视这种心理复杂性。经济学家创造了一个将人们视作理性经济人的原型。这种简化使得经济学家能够使用数学模型来描述人们的行为，但他们忽略了影响我们选择的广泛心理因素。理查德的异常现象清单中的人们，并不仅仅试图最大化他们的经济自身利益。相反，他们受到情感、担忧和偏见的引导。你可以称这种行为是不理性的，但理查德说他不喜欢这个词。原因在于它对不同的人带有各种各样的含义。如果你说某件事
is not rational, then that sounds pejorative. And in some cases some of the things we've talked about should be considered illogical, let's say. But economic rationality is this concept that people solve by optimizing. And if they're solving in some other way, it may or may not be optimal. So, you know, my friend Cassanstein and I like to say that we don't think people are dumb, we think the world is hard. We have a model that says people will do A
是不理性的，那听起来带有贬义。在某些情况下，我们讨论过的一些事情应该被认为是不符合逻辑的，比方说。但经济理性是一个人们通过优化来解决问题的概念。如果他们用其他方式来解决，它可能是也可能不是最优的。所以，你知道的，我和我的朋友卡斯·桑斯坦喜欢说，我们不认为人们是笨的，我们认为世界是艰难的。我们有一个模型说人们会做A
and we observe B. So these are violations of economic theory. And so I try, especially in my writing to a popular audience, to avoid that word when I can. You know, one of the things that we haven't quite touched on is that some of the models predict that people will act essentially always in their own self-interest. And there's been a lot of work that's looked at the issue of tipping. You go to a strange new city, you're passing through for a night, you're never gonna the meal. You're never going to see them again. So there's no real sense of if I tip them, I'm going to get better service when I come next time. You can
而我们观察到B。所以这些是对经济学理论的违背。因此我尽量避免使用那个词，尤其是在面向大众的写作中，只要我能做到的话。你知道，我们还没有完全触及的一点是，其中一些模型预测人们本质上总是会为了自身的利益而行动。有很多研究都关注过小费的问题。你到一个陌生而崭新的城市，你在那里过夜，你再也不会……这顿饭。你再也不会见到他们了。所以并没有这种真实的意识：如果我给他们小费，下次我来的时候就会得到更好的服务。你可以
leave without paying a tip because in fact, you would save 20% on your bill. And yet, in every part of the country, and perhaps every part of the world, people don't do this because what's best for them is not just what's best for their checkbooks. Yeah, and again, this is a good follow-up to the discussion of rationality because this is clearly a case where we don't want to say that leaving a tip in a strange restaurant is irrational. What we can say is that it became a social norm, which isn't really explaining it as much as giving it a name. And of course, social norms are not the same around the world. So in much of Europe, tipping is not the norm. In France, it used to be that when you paid in cash that you
离开时不付小费，因为事实上，你的账单可以省下20%。然而，在国家的每个角落，或许在世界的每个角落，人们都不这样做，因为对他们最好的不仅仅是他们的钱包最好的部分。是的，再次说明，这是对理性讨论的一个很好的后续，因为这显然是一个我们不想说在陌生餐馆给小费是不理性的案例。我们可以说的是，这成了一种社会规范，这与其说是在解释它，不如说是在给它起个名字。当然，社会规范在世界各地并非都是一样的。所以在欧洲的大部分地区，给小费并不是常规。在法国，过去当你用现金支付时，你
would sort of round up whereas in the US I remember being in the cab in New York and in a big hurry getting off at a train station and the fare was 9.50 and I gave the driver $10 and got out of the cabin ran and he threw a quarter at me. So tipping is not always completely voluntary. But the idea that social norms play a huge role in our behavior is a powerful idea because of course, you can ask what is maximizing your benefit. But maximizing your benefit is not just about paying as little as you can because we care about our social repetitions, we care about what other people think of us, all these things mounted to us.
会四舍五入，而在美国，我记得我在纽约坐出租车，非常匆忙地在一个火车站下车，车费是9.50美元，我给了司机10美元，然后下车跑了，他朝我扔了一个25美分的硬币。所以给小费并不总是完全自愿的。但社会规范在我们的行为中发挥着巨大作用这一观点是一个强有力的观点，因为当然，你可以问什么是最大化你的利益。但最大化你的利益不仅仅是关于尽可能少付钱，因为我们关心我们的社会声誉，我们关心别人怎么看我们，所有这些事情对我们都很重要。
Right. I mean, most of us don't walk around naked. Now there are certain neighborhoods in San Francisco where there are different social norms. And there are some beaches that there are different social norms. But we all follow many social norms. So now a compilation of your friends and colleagues doing odd things is not really grist for an academic paper or an academic career. And for a long time, your list remained just that, a list, a collection of anecdotes. But at one point, you stumbled across the work
对。我的意思是，我们大多数人不会赤身裸体到处走。现在旧金山确实有些街区有不同的社会规范。有些海滩也有不同的社会规范。但我们所有人都遵循许多社会规范。所以现在，你的朋友和同事们做奇怪事情的汇编，并不是学术论文或学术生涯的真正好素材。很长一段时间里，你的清单依然只是个清单，一个轶事的集合。但有那么一刻，你偶然发现了
of Amos Torski and Danny Kahneman, tell me how you encountered that work Richard and the effect that it had on you. So yeah, I sometimes joke that my greatest scientific discovery was discovering Amos Tversky and Daniel Coniman. They claim to have existed before my, but this is a discovery sort of the way Columbus was alleged to have discovered America. So I was at a conference and I met one of their graduate students and ended up talking to him for quite a while and he was a psychologist so I told him some of the stories on my list and he said you know you would be interested in the research that my advisors have been doing.
阿莫斯·特沃斯基和丹尼·卡尼曼的工作，理查德，告诉我你是如何接触到那项工作的，它对你产生了什么影响。所以，是的，我有时开玩笑说，我最伟大的科学发现是发现了阿莫斯·特沃斯基和丹尼尔·卡尼曼。他们声称在我之前就存在了，但这是一种发现，就像哥伦布被指称发现了美洲一样。所以我当时在参加一个会议，我遇到了他们的一个研究生，最后和他聊了挺久，他是个心理学家，所以我告诉了他我清单上的一些故事，他说，你知道的，你一定会对我的导师们一直在做的研究感兴趣。
Those advisors, Amos Tversky and Daniel Kahneman, were blazing a trail in the field now known as behavioral economics. They were interested in a range of cognitive biases that shape how we see the world, make predictions about the future, and grapple with wins and losses. Richard was intrigued. And so, when he got back to the University of Rochester, he made a point to look up their research.
那些导师，阿莫斯·特沃斯基和丹尼尔·卡尼曼，正在如今被称为行为经济学的领域开辟道路。他们对塑造我们如何看待世界、对未来做出预测以及如何处理得失的一系列认知偏差很感兴趣。理查德很感兴趣。所以，当他回到罗切斯特大学时，他特意去查阅了他们的研究。
And when I got back to Rochester, I had to go find a new section of the library, because I was used to be the economic section, and now I'm on the psychology floor. And the first paper I read was a paper that's now very famous in 1974, paper in science, called Judgment Under Uncertain uncertainty heuristics and biases. And it was sort of the little greatest hits collection of a series of papers they had written in the early 70s. And the phrase heuristics and biases is very well chosen and insightful. So, there work can be summarized in the following
当我回到罗切斯特时，我不得不去寻找图书馆的一个新区域，因为我以前习惯了经济学区，而现在我在心理学楼层。我读的第一篇论文现在在1974年非常著名，是发表在《科学》杂志上的一篇论文，名为《不确定性下的判断：启发法与偏差》。它可以说是他们在70年代初写的一系列论文的“小精选集”。而“启发法与偏差”这个短语选得非常好，而且很有洞察力。所以，他们的工作可以总结为以下
way. Life is complicated. We use rules of thumb to help us. Euristics is a fancy word for rules of thumb. And using those makes sense because those rules of thumb are usually useful. That's why they exist. But they also have predictable biases. So you know, a famous example is the availability heuristic, which is that we judge the frequency of something by how easy it is to recall instances of that type. So if you ask people what's more common homicides or suicide? People think homicides by maybe two to one, and the opposite is true.
方式。生活是复杂的。我们使用经验法则来帮助自己。“启发法”是经验法则的一个fancy（高大上）词汇。使用这些是有意义的，因为这些经验法则通常很有用。这就是它们存在的原因。但它们也有可预测的偏差。所以你知道的，一个著名的例子是可用性启发法，也就是说，我们通过回忆起该类型实例的容易程度来判断某事的频率。所以如果你问人们什么更常见：他杀还是自杀？人们认为是他杀，比例可能是二比一，而事实恰好相反。
Suicides are about twice as likely. And what you think about it, you realize why? Well, homicides get lots of publicity. Suicides tend to be quiet. But the big light bulb that went off when I was reading this paper was the word bias and the idea of systematic bias. What Richard means by systematic bias
自杀的可能性大约是前者的两倍。当你仔细想想，你就会明白为什么？嗯，凶杀案得到了很多宣传。自杀往往是悄无声息的。但当我读这篇论文时，亮起的大灯泡是“偏差”这个词以及系统性偏差的概念。理查德所说的系统性偏差
is that there were regularities to the anomalies he had collected. These were not merely a collection of weird unrelated behaviors. Instead, they pointed to underlying patterns. You know, my stories, economists would brush the mason, usually with the phrase, well look, yeah, we all know that people make mistakes. But if the mistakes are random, then economic theory is fine.
是指他收集的异常现象具有规律性。这些不仅仅是一堆奇怪的、不相关的行为。相反，它们指向了潜在的模式。你知道的，对于我的故事，经济学家们会不屑一顾，通常用这样一句话：“看吧，是的，我们都知道人们会犯错。”但如果错误是随机的，那么经济学理论就没有问题。
Now, if the errors are all in the same direction, then we're going to have a bias. So if we go back to the sunk cost fallacy, we know that the economic theory says the amount of money you paid for that ticket is irrelevant. And we know absolutely for sure that the amount of money you paid will be a very good predictor of how likely you are to drive in a snowstorm or go sit in the rain. drive in a snowstorm or go sit in the rain. And in fact, as you were telling the stories on your list,
现在，如果错误都朝着同一个方向，那么我们就会产生偏差。因此，如果我们回到沉没成本谬误，我们知道经济学理论说你为那张票付出的金钱是无关紧要的。而我们绝对确定的是，你付出的金钱金额将成为预测你是否会在暴风雪中开车或去雨中枯坐的高效指标。在暴风雪中开车或去雨中枯坐。事实上，当你在讲你清单上的故事时，
I found myself asking what I would do if I was in one of your stories. And in every one of those cases, my intuition about how I would behave lined up precisely with the way that people actually did behave. So I would be very happy sitting in your living room if you took away the bowl of cashews. I would drink a bottle of wine that has become quite expensive just by virtue of sitting around for 20 years, but I would hesitate to buy a bottle of wine that is very expensive.
我发现自己在想，如果我处于你的一个故事中，我会怎么做。在每一个案例中，我对自己的行为方式的直觉都与人们实际的行为方式完全一致。所以，如果你把一碗腰果拿走，我会非常高兴地坐在你的客厅里。我会喝一瓶因为放了20年而变得非常昂贵的酒，但我会犹豫是否要买一瓶非常昂贵的酒。
And absolutely, if I paid several hundred dollars for a concert ticket, I would drive through a hurricane to make it to the event. Right. So, you know, I sometimes say that the things I discovered were only surprising to economists. And so it's interesting, you know, there's one group of people that are sure you're wrong and the other people are sure that why is this news to anybody.
而且绝对地，如果我为一张音乐会门票花了几百美元，我会顶着飓风开车去参加活动。对。所以，你知道的，我有时会说，我发现的事情只让经济学家感到惊讶。所以这很有趣，你知道的，有一群人确信你是错的，而另一群人则确信这为什么会是任何人的新闻。
When we come back, how the scientific study of supposedly irrelevant factors, birthed the creation of a new field of study and became a powerful vehicle for understanding human nature. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Richard Thaler is the author of Misbehaving, the Making of Behavioral Economics. Early in his career as an economist, he noticed people often fail to act in the ways models of economists might predict. He collected stories of friends and colleagues behaving in this manner. But a collection of anecdotes is not science. Richard started running experiments to see if the
当我们回来时，对所谓的无关因素的科学研究，是如何催生出一个新的研究领域，并成为理解人性的强大工具的。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。理查德·塞勒是《错误的行为：行为经济学的诞生》一书的作者。在他经济学家生涯的早期，他注意到人们经常无法按照经济学家模型所预测的方式行事。他收集了朋友和同事以这种方式行事的风趣故事。但一堆轶事并不是科学。理查德开始进行实验，看看
behavior of his friends and colleagues were generalizable. One of the items on your list that we haven't talked about, Richard, involves a friend of yours who was buying a clock radio and eventually the story turned into an experiment that you published in a paper in 1980. Tell me the story about the clock radio. Well the story of the clock radio was and it's funny now, I'm thinking people don't even know what clock radios are. But somebody's going to buy a clock radio and it costs $25 and they get to the store and the clerk says actually this same radio is on sale at our other branch for $20.
他的朋友和同事的行为是否具有普遍性。理查德，你清单上有一项我们还没谈过的事情，涉及你的一个朋友，他在买一个时钟收音机，最终这个故事变成了一个实验，你在1980年的一篇论文中发表了它。跟我讲讲关于时钟收音机的故事吧。嗯，时钟收音机的故事是这样的——现在想来挺搞笑的，我想人们现在甚至都不知道时钟收音机是什么了。但某人要去买一个时钟收音机，它要25美元，他们到了商店，店员说，其实同一款收音机在我们的另一家分店正以20美元促销。
You could go buy it there. And then there's another version of this story that you're buying a television set that costs $500 and the clerk says, well, this television is on sale for $495, that the other branch of the store, the other branch 20 minutes away, would you drive? So in both cases, you're saving five bucks. In both cases, you're saving five bucks for 20 minutes and no one even thinks about doing it for the large purchase, but many think they should do it for the small purchase. And the first episode science was just to ask
你可以去那里买。然后这个故事还有另一个版本：你在买一台价值500美元的电视机，店员说，这台电视机正在以495美元促销，在商店的另一家分店，另一家20分钟路程的分店，你会开车去吗？所以在这两种情况下，你都省了五块钱。在这两种情况下，你为了5省块钱都要开20分钟的车，而且没有人会考虑为了大额购买去做这件事，但许多人认为他们应该为了小额购买去做这件事。而《科学》杂志上的第一集只是去问
people those questions, you know, get one group to answer the radio question and others to answer the television question and show that... There was a gulf between them. Yeah, and that people's intuitions lined up with my story. I would say that kind of experiment would not impress economists today,
人们这些问题，你知道的，让一组回答收音机的问题，另一组回答电视的问题，并表明……它们之间存在一条鸿沟。是的，人们的直觉与我的故事是一致的。我会说这种实验在今天的经济学家看来不会留下深刻印象，
but it was at least a step toward science. Remember the story about the wine bottle worth $200? That Richard's professor would need a buy for $200? Nor sell for $200? Richard came up with an experiment to demonstrate that idea too. Danny Connerman and I ran an experiment to illustrate the same point. And in this case we used coffee mugs. And this was done at Cornell later done at many other universities. But we would put coffee mugs
但它至少是迈向科学的一步。还记得那个价值200美元的酒瓶的故事吗？理查德的教授需要花200美元买下来？也不肯以200美元卖掉？理查德想出一个实验来证明那个观点。丹尼·卡尼曼和我做了一个实验来说明同样的观点。在这个例子中，我们使用了咖啡马克杯。这是后来在康奈尔大学以及许多其他大学完成的。我们会把咖啡马克杯
on every other desk and then say, if you got a coffee mug, it's yours. If you didn't, you should look at the person's mug next to you and examine it. And now we're going to have a market for mugs. And the people who have mugs fill out a form at each of the following prices, would they be willing to give up their mug? Say, start at $10 and go down in 50 cent increments? And then the people who don't have a mug
放在每隔一张桌子上，然后说，如果你拿到了一个咖啡马克杯，它就是你的。如果你没有，你应该看看你旁边的人的杯子并检查一下。现在我们要建立一个马克杯市场。拥有马克杯的人在以下每个价格下填写表格：他们是否愿意放弃他们的马克杯？比如，从10美元开始，以50美分为单位递减？然后是没有马克杯的人
at the following prices, would you be willing to buy? Now, if people assign a value to this mug, they should be willing to buy if the price is less than their value and sell if it's greater. And we've handed out the mugs at random. So buying and selling prices for the two groups should be about the same. And that implies that about half of the mugs should change hands. And what we found was there was very little trading, much less than half, and that's because the people who had mugs demanded twice as much to give it up, as the people who didn't were willing to pay to get one. And this is what
在以下价格下：你愿意买吗？现在，如果人们为这个杯子赋予了价值，如果价格低于他们的价值，他们就应该愿意买；如果价格高于价值，他们就应该愿意卖。我们是随机分发马克杯的。所以这两组人的买入价和卖出价应该差不多。这意味着大约一半的马克杯应该易手。而我们发现的是，交易非常少，远低于一半，这是因为拥有马克杯的人要求两倍的价钱才肯放弃它，而没有马克杯的人愿意支付的价钱则要低得多。这就是
I had back in the day called the endowment effect that you demand more to give something up than you'd be willing to pay to get it. And here we were showing this for an object this foreign object you had owned for a minute. It's Danny like to call this the instant endowment effect. Yeah, and you can see how this might work at a larger scale. If I'm selling a house to you, I've lived in that house for 15 years, and now I'm trying to sell it to you Richard, I'm going to value that house significantly higher than you might value it if you're the if you're the buyer Well, that's right and
我当年所称的“禀赋效应”，即你要求更多的东西才肯放弃，而你愿意支付的价钱则要少得多。在这里，我们针对一件物品——一件你只拥有了一分钟的外在物品——展示了这一点。丹尼喜欢把这叫做“瞬间禀赋效应”。是的，你可以看到这在更大规模上是如何运作的。如果我要把一栋房子卖给你，我在那栋房子里住了15年，现在我正试图把它卖给你，理查德，我对那栋房子的估价会明显高于如果你是买家时的估价。好吧，那是对的，而且
It it explains partly why it can be hard to assemble a parcel of land without the right of eminent domain Because people who've been living in a house all their life would demand a lot to give it up much more than the market price. Now again, we don't want to say whether that's rational or irrational, there could be lots of sentiment and so forth. But there's no sentimental attachment to a coffee mag that I've owned for one minute. Yeah, but you can see how powerful this effect might be
这在一定程度上解释了为什么在没有征用权的情况下很难组装一块土地，因为那些一辈子都住在房子里的人会要求很高的补偿才肯放弃，远高于市场价。现在，我们同样不想说这是理性的还是不理性的，这里面可能有很多情感因素等等。但对于一个我只拥有了一分钟的咖啡马克杯，可没有什么情感依恋。是的，但你可以看到这种效应会有多么强大，
in all manner of economic transactions, because of course every economic transaction involves someone being willing to give up something that they have in exchange for money and somebody being willing to pay money to acquire something. If people are systematically, this is not just a question of the sellers wanting to make as much money as they could and the buyers wanting to pay as little as they could. It's not just that. It's also the fact that they're actually valuing the thing differently.
以各种各样的经济交易方式，因为当然每笔经济交易都涉及某人愿意放弃他们拥有的东西来换取金钱，以及某人愿意付钱来获取某些东西。如果人们系统性地——这不仅仅是卖家想尽可能多赚钱、买家想尽可能少付钱的问题。不仅如此。这也是因为他们实际上对事物的价值进行了不同的评估。
They genuinely feel, once I have the mug, this mug actually is worth $10 and when I don't have the mug, the mug genuinely feels like it's only worth $5. Right. Obviously, we want to see, fall, what you observe when that happens is, prices don't fall as much as volume falls. So you just see no houses changing hands. And the reason for that is that, let's suppose that you have some house that similar houses were selling for 500,000 a year ago. And you could now only get 450. Well, you say, look, my neighbor sold his house for 500. I'm not going to take 450. My house is better than his.
他们真诚地觉得，一旦我有了这个杯子，这个杯子实际上就值10美元；而当我没有这个杯子时，这个杯子真诚地感觉只值5美元。对。显然，我们想要看到的是，当这种情况发生时，价格的下跌并没有交易量的下跌那么大。所以你只是看不到房子易手。其原因在于，假设你有一套房子，类似的房子在一年以五万的价格出售。而你现在只能拿到四万五。好吧，你会说，看，我的邻居以五万卖了他的房子。我才不接受四万五。我的房子比他的好。
Whereas the buyers say, well, no, prices have fallen. I'm not going to pay more than. And so you just see people are unable to agree on a price. And it can take several years. If the price is going down is permanent. It takes quite a while for the owners to realize, well, if they're going to want to sell this thing, they're going to have to lower the price. This is the new price. Yeah. We talked earlier about the idea of mental accounting, which is we have different mental buckets in our heads. And this is always one of the domains of your work that has fascinated me for the longest
而买家会说，不，价格已经下跌了。我不会支付超过……所以你只是看到人们无法就价格达成一致。这可能需要几年时间。如果价格下降是永久性的，房主需要相当长的一段时间才能意识到，好吧，如果他们想要卖掉这东西，他们将不得不降低价格。这就是新价格。是的。我们之前讨论过心理账户的概念，也就是我们脑海中有不同的心理桶。这也是你的工作中长期以来一直让我着迷的领域之一
time as well. In 1997, you published a paper with Colin Kamera, Linda Babcock, and George Lohanstein looking at taxi drivers in New York City. Tell me about that study, what you did and what you found. So, yeah, let me tell you the background. Colin Kammerer and I, along with Andy Connerman, were spending a year in New York City visiting the Russell Sage Foundation. And Colin and I were spending a lot of time together, taking cabs, and we would
很长一段时间。1997年，你与科林·卡梅勒、琳达·巴布科克和乔治·洛温斯坦合作发表了一篇论文，研究纽约市的出租车司机。跟我讲讲那项研究，你们做了什么，又发现了什么。所以，是的，让我讲讲背景。科林·卡梅勒和我，还有安迪·卡尼曼，在纽约市度过了一年，访问罗素·萨奇基金会。科林和我花了很多时间在一起，坐出租车，我们会
talk to the cab drivers, and we started asking them how they decided how long to work each day. And the way it worked was they would pay a certain amount, say $100, to rent the cab for 12 hours. And the rule was you had to return the cab full of gas before the 12 hours was up. But most drivers didn't want to work that much. So we would ask them, okay, how do you decide how much to work? And many told us that they had a target amount of income they wanted to make. So they had to pay for the rental of the cab and the gas and let's say their target is $100 per day above expenses. When they hit that, they would quit. Now, some days are busier than others. So, for example, on rainy days, cab drivers make a lot more money because
和出租车司机交谈，我们开始问他们是如何决定每天工作多长时间的。它是这样运作的：他们会支付一定的金额，比方说100美元，来租用出租车12个小时。规则是，在12小时结束之前，你必须把加满油的出租车还回去。但大多数司机不想工作那么久。所以我们会问他们，好吧，你们是怎么决定工作多久的？许多人告诉我们，他们有一个想要赚取的收入目标。所以他们必须支付出租车租金和油费，比方说他们的目标是每天扣除开支后赚100美元。当他们达到这个目标时，他们就会收工。现在，有些日子比其他日子更忙。所以，例如，在雨天，出租车司机赚的钱要多得多，因为
they spend more time with people paying and less time driving around looking for customers. But if they have a target income, it means that they worked less on busy days and worked more on slow days. So they could make more money slow days. So they could make more money just by flipping that work a lot on the days where you're making a lot of money. And then on slow days, go home and play with the kids. And we found evidence to support this. Turns out this paper became controversial. There were lots of papers back and forth. Does this happen? Doesn't it happen?
他们花更多的时间在付钱的乘客身上，而花在开车寻找顾客上的时间更少。但如果他们有一个收入目标，那就意味着他们在忙碌的日子里工作较少，而在生意清淡的日子里工作较多。所以他们本可以通过在生意兴隆的日子里努力工作来赚更多的钱。然后在生意清淡的日子里，回家和孩子们玩耍。我们找到了支持这一点的证据。事实证明，这篇论文引发了争议。有大量的论文争论不休。这会发生吗？不会发生吗？
I believe the current view is, yes, it does happen. But this is a good example of how the field is progressing. So we start with an anecdote, and then we do a survey, and then we do an experiment with for real money with those mugs. And now we're going out and studying actual labor supply decisions of real people in their work environment. It's always getting closer to studying the real world. It's always getting closer to studying the real world.
我相信目前的观点是，是的，这确实会发生。但这很好地说明了该领域是如何发展的。所以我们从一个轶事开始，然后我们做一个调查，然后我们用那些马克杯为真钱做一个实验。现在我们出去研究真实环境中真实人们的实际劳动力供应决策。它总是越来越接近研究现实世界。它总是越来越接近研究现实世界。
Richard, you once looked at how teams select players in the NFL draft. For our overseas listeners who are unfamiliar with American football, the 32 teams in the league get to pick new players each year. And to even out the quality of players on different teams, the league allows the team that has the worst record the previous year to pick first. Obviously they get to select the strongest player. The strongest team from the previous year gets to pick last, meaning they are likely to get weaker players. Now an important quark of the system is that
理查德，你曾经研究过球队在NFL选秀中是如何挑选球员的。对于不熟悉美式橄榄球的海外听众来说，联盟中的32支球队每年都可以挑选新球员。为了平衡不同球队的球员实力，联盟允许前一年战绩最差的球队拥有第一顺位挑选权。显然，他们可以挑选最强的球员。前一年实力最强的球队则获得倒数第一顺位，这意味着他们可能会得到实力较弱的球员。现在，这个系统的一个重要奇特之处在于，
where you get drafted eventually determines how much you get paid. So teams drafting players early are on the hook eventually to pay the top players more. Now most teams of course want to pick as early in the draft as possible. But along with the researcher at Yale, you analyzed where the best deals were in the NFL draft and you eventually wrote a paper about your findings titled The Losers Curse. What did you find Richard? So yeah, this is a paper I wrote with a former student named Kayne Massey. And what we found was teams really value going first. You can trade the first pick for the eighth and ninth picks. So that's saying the eighth pick is worth half as much as the first pick.
你在哪个顺位被选中，最终决定了你的薪水。因此，过早选中球员的球队最终不得不向顶级球员支付更多薪水。当然，大多数球队都希望在选秀中尽可能早地挑选。但是，你与耶鲁大学的研究人员一起，分析了NFL选秀中最划算的交易在哪里，并最终写了一篇关于你们发现的论文，名为《失败者的诅咒》。理查德，你们发现了什么？是的，这是我和我的前学生凯恩·马西合著的一篇论文。我们发现的是，球队非常重视获得状元签。你可以用状元签去换第八和第九顺位。所以也就是说，第八顺位的价值只有状元签的一半。
Even though you're gonna have to pay the first pick more about twice as much. And you could trade the first pick for five or six players in the second round, meaning the players ranked 33 to 64. So the teams are acting as if the right to pick first is really valuable, that you're going to get Tom Brady or Leon O'Messy if he, if he played American football. Now, that's in spite of the fact that Tom Brady was taken with
尽管你必须为状元签支付更多薪水，大约是两倍。而且你可以用状元签换取第二轮的五到六名球员，也就是排名在第33到第64位的球员。因此，球队的表现就好像拥有第一挑选权非常宝贵，你会得到汤姆·布雷迪或莱昂·梅西（如果他踢美式橄榄球的话）。现在，这是在以下事实的基础上的：汤姆·布雷迪当时是在
the 199th pick. So teams are not very good at knowing who's going to be the great player down the road. Yes. So here's one fact that illustrates that. We called this, Katie and I used to call this the better than the next guy analysis. We took all the players at a given position, say quarterback, and we put them in the order in which they were picked, ranked from first to last. And then we said, what's the probability that the player chosen earlier is better than the player chosen next? Now notice if teams are perfect, that'll be 100%. If it's random, it'll be 50%. In our sample, it was 53%. Wow. Wow. So basically, they're throwing dark to this point. Yes. It's a little higher in the first round. It might be 55 percent, but they're acting like it's 80 percent. And actually, we've recently been going through and re-analysing this data,
第199顺位被选中的。所以球队并不太擅长预判谁会成为未来的伟大球员。是的。有一个事实可以说明这一点。我们称之为——凯蒂和我过去称之为“比下一个家伙更好”的分析。我们把某个特定位置（比如传球手）的所有球员拿出来，按照他们被选中的顺序排列，从第一名排到最后一名。然后我们问，较早被选中的球员比接下来的球员更优秀的概率是多少？现在请注意，如果球队是完美的，这个概率将是100%。如果是随机的，将是50%。在我们的样本中，它是53%。哇。哇。所以基本上，他们在这个问题上是在盲目猜测。是的。在第一轮中这个比例会稍微高一点，可能是55%，但他们的表现却好像有80%一样。事实上，我们最近一直在复查和重新分析这些数据，
asking the question, have teams learned anything in the 20 years since we wrote this paper and the answer is no. Nothing has changed. Yeah. It's also what's mentioning here that teams have a cap in the amount of money that they can spend. So it's not like they have an infinite pool of money they can spend in waste. In fact, money that you waste on player A is money that you could have
提出了这样一个问题：在写这篇论文之后的20年里，球队学到了什么吗？答案是，没有。没有什么改变。是的。这里也值得一提的是，球队在花费的金额上有个上限。所以这并不是说他们有花不完的钱可以随意挥霍。事实上，你在A球员身上浪费的钱，本来是可以
spent better getting players BC and D. And so in fact, if you misprice players, you're paying a very large cost as an organization. Yeah. So this is a very important point and especially for the non-US listeners. The The National Football League has a salary cap. It's really an economic budgeting problem. How can I get the best team without spending more than X? And so if you get a player that turns out to be very good and very cheap, then that's worth a lot. Richard Taylor helped to develop the foundation of what is today known as Behavioral Economics. His work has transformed away many companies and nations construct models of human behavior. Richard was awarded the Nobel Prize
花得更好去买B、C和D球员的。因此，事实上，如果你对球员定价错误，作为一家机构，你将付出非常巨大的代价。是的。所以这是一个非常重要的点，特别是对于非美国听众来说。美国国家橄榄球联盟有一个薪资上限。这其实是一个经济预算问题。我如何在不超过X的情况下组建最好的球队？因此，如果你得到一个最终表现得非常好且非常便宜的球员，那将非常有价值。理查德·泰勒协助奠定了当今被称为“行为经济学”的基础。他的工作改变了许多公司和国家构建人类行为模型的方式。理查德被授予了
for Economics in 2017. You can read more about these ideas in his book, Misbehaving, the Making of Behavioral Economics. Richard Thaler, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. If you enjoyed today's episode, we have a special treat for you. Richard Thaler did not merely create a compendium of ways that human beings failed to act like the rational economic actors in mathematical models. Much of his research that eventually led to his Nobel Prize came after the work described in this episode.
2017年诺贝尔经济学奖。你可以在他的书《错误的行为：行为经济学的形成》中阅读更多关于这些理念的内容。理查德·泰勒，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。如果你喜欢今天的节目，我们为你准备了一份特别的厚礼。理查德·泰勒不仅创造了一个人类未能像数学模型中的理性经济人那样行事的行为清单。他最终获得诺贝尔经济学奖的大部分研究，都来自于本集节目中所描述的工作之后。
We explored the complexities of that research in a special bonus episode for listeners to our subscription feed, Hidden Brain Plus. It explores ways, rich odds ideas have revolutionized everything from tax collection to retirement planning to the aim of men at your knows and airport bathrooms. Some men failed to aim properly. And the solution was to etch the image of a house fly
我们在订阅源《隐藏的大脑Plus》的一集特别的特别节目中，探讨了这些研究的复杂性。它探讨了理查德的理念如何彻底改变了从税收筹划、退休规划到男士小便池和机场卫生间的瞄准目标等各个领域。一些男士无法准确瞄准。而解决方案是在
near the drain. And if you give a man a target, he will aim. So the report was that spillage went down considerably although I've not been able to check those data but the house floods have appeared in other airports around the world. If you are signed up already you can listen to that episode right now. If not, try Hidden Brain Plus for free for 7 days on the Apple Podcasts app or by going to apple.co slash Hidden Brain.
排水口附近蚀刻一只家蝇的图像。如果你给男人一个目标，他就会去瞄准。因此，据报道，溅洒液体的情况大大减少，尽管我无法核实这些数据，但家蝇图案已经出现在世界各地的其他机场。如果你已经注册了，你现在就可以收听那一集。如果没有，请在Apple Podcasts应用上或通过访问apple.co/hiddenbrain免费试用《隐藏的大脑Plus》7天。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Paul Carabush. Paul is the audio engineer at the audio studio at the University of Chicago's Boots School of Business. He helps set up the studio and ensure a high quality recording of our conversation with Richard Thaler. Thank you so much Paul. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保尔、克里斯滕·黄、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是保罗·卡拉布什。保罗是芝加哥大学布斯商学院音频工作室的音频工程师。他协助搭建了工作室，并确保了我们与理查德·泰勒对话的高品质录音。非常感谢你，保罗。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。你。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。